اسمي مريم عبد الله
اربع سنوات من ال 48 ل 52
كعائلتي اللي هو ابوي وامي واختي
من 48 ل 52 تستقروا
اولادنا وشتات الناس وضارب وقتل وسجن
واخذ اراضي ودور
وباخذ الاراضي وباخذ الناس احنا في سجن
يعني اطلعي على اطلع مثلا هليكوبتر او
اطلع على كاميرا صوري المخيم
هذا المعبر كثير خانت معبر رئيسي معبر
قلنديا
وكثير يعني طخوا عليه ناس فتيات وشباب انا
عمري
اليوم كان اللحظه هذا استشهد
يعني اللي قاعد بصير في البلاد تهجير
الناس لاهل القدس من القدس للمناطق دورهم
كذا
ساكن المخيم بس اصلي انا
بنساش بلدي
حاليا انا بحلم ازور بلدي مصارعه بعيد
عنها قديش اقل من ساعه 38 سنه ما اعرفش
اروح عليها النهايه يعني سواء انا اللي
اخذتها ولاولاد واولاد اولادي راح نست
البلد
ظل فيه رمان شلاح الثواب اللي زي هذا علي
وشلحت الفستان اللي تحته مليت رمان